we are going to be talking later today
with Anand egirdir das about the way in
which corporations and corporate media
narrowed the scope of what is acceptable
activism and acceptable change and part
of that comes with evaluating the sort
of status quo about our politicians
which is increasingly a sort of
expectation that they be rich and
successful and that if they aren't
there's something wrong with them and
Fox News case in point made fun of
congresswoman elect Alexandria Acacio
Cortes who has the traits of not only
being young I believe I always forget
that is she the youngest congresswoman
ever or not a 2000 years old I don't
believe so just cuz the country goes
back so far but certainly the most the
youngest congresswoman elect a youngest
person that we currently have in
Congress she will become right she will
be the youngest of the incoming Congress
I think we can say with certitude um and
and another characteristic about her is
that she's not wealthy and there's
nothing wrong with that and there's
nothing to make fun of there but one of
the problems with our politics is that
it has become this sort of game for the
rich on average members of Congress and
even more so in the Senate have way more
money than the average American way more
money even than the average American at
the same age as that member of Congress
and we increasingly have this political
system that is corporations and rich
people influencing the way that the
likewise rich members of Congress govern
the country it's sort of by rich people
for rich people and corporations and
this is a toxic reality I mean this is
one of the worst things about our
politics right now one of the best
things that we could do aside from
campaign finance reform and net
neutrality and dealing with the climate
right the sort of base core issues we
discuss one of the best things we could
do is have a group of people
representing us that is more
representative more economically diverse
more diverse in terms of background
meaning fewer lawyers and businesspeople
and more people from science and
education and other
areas I have many disagreements
politically with Alexandria Acacio
Cortez I think that there are many fair
criticisms about her lack of knowledge
in certain areas and hopefully she will
learn more by doing now that she's going
to be an elected member of Congress but
when it comes to simply not fitting the
mold of being a rich lawyer or a wealthy
business person who's going to be in
Congress that is a completely misguided
criticism of her she has made no secret
of the fact that she's financially
limited
she's so financially limited in fact
that we learned that she is going to
have a nice salary of $174,000 a year
starting in January when she's sworn in
but she's going to have to wait for that
to kick in before she even gets an
apartment in Washington DC there's a New
York Times interview where it was
reported that Ms Acacio Cortez said the
transition period will be very unusual
because I can't really take a salary I
have three months without a salary
before I'm a member of Congress so how
do I get an apartment these little
things are very real she said she saved
money before leaving her job at the
restaurant and planned accordingly with
her partner were kind of just dealing
with the logistics of it day by day but
I've really been just kind of
squirreling away and then hoping that
gets me to January that's fine
DC is expensive she I think has never
had well-paying jobs who's surprised
that affording an apartment in DC is a
difficult thing
well Fox News made fun of her for it
everybody just laughing having a grand
old time
what exactly is funny about this
Alexandria okay CEO Cortez she says that
she's having a hard time with something
Stanford do we have an hour should I
wait okay let me know when we have it so
Alexandria for us okay CEO Cortes says
this I have three months without a
salary before I'm a member of Congress
so how do I get an apartment those
little things are very real she said
this to the New York Times they think of
that it's very
Andrea aunt Sandra gives you a quartet
to say this I think her supporters like
it this is who she is comes from the
Bronx she's young youngest member of
Congress it's tough to get an apartment
in DC I also think she's not alone she
might be the only one talking about it
but a lot of congressmen in Washington
DC say given the cost of living there
it's not exactly the Washington I dream
I think that was preceded by a year and
a half ago I was tending bar in Brooklyn
which is true by the way that's playing
to a race but the fact of matter is
Washington DC and the greater
metropolitan area is the most expensive
Cathy in America now so if I think what
she's talking about is all of the money
in Washington all of the wealth in
Washington all of the power and a little
simple person like her from New York can
find a place to live it is a brilliant
political line on the other hand for a
resume that shall we just mentioned
about being from the Bronx it turns out
when you read deeper she had a lot more
formative years in Westchester County
New York a little riskier than the Bronx
I'm from New York
and I want to throw stones in any
boroughs or counties but she her resume
I was always mentioned and some of those
shoots during the campaign she had these
multi-thousand dollar outfits that could
pay a month's rent in Washington DC
you're right well I live in Washington
it's very expensive but she's been all
over the map on some of this stuff this
is the stupas stupidest commentary I
could imagine it's a brilliant political
move to say she can't afford an
apartment or this plays well with her
supporters she just can't afford the
apartment and she had expensive outfits
and photo shoots you don't get to keep
those outfits that's not a contradiction
and still they're mispronouncing her
name I get it if you don't speak Spanish
you might have trouble with Ocasio but
occasio okay where is they they still
can't pronounce her name and then she
actually tweeted a response to this
three-part response and number one why
can't any of your anchors say my name
correctly it's been five months which I
concur number two it's bizarre to see 1%
salaried anchors laugh at the US housing
crisis absolutely spot-on and number
three never purchased pricey clothes
always told my story but repeating
until they are believed is your thing
the undertone here is she's not
qualified to be a congresswoman since
she's not rich I find it refreshing to
have this be the situation and implicit
in this obviously is that people who
aren't rich aren't smart even though the
right claims to be for working people
and you've got fox news anchors who are
completely out of touch with the reality
that 60% of Americans aren't able to
handle an unexpected $400 emergency I
think the numbers were Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez is in touch with that I think
that's one of her good qualities it's a
feature and not a bug
these people are vile and they are
perpetuating the exact problem that I'm
going to talk about after the break with
Ananda gear Dardis follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on instagram at david pakman one of
today's David Pakman show sponsors is
debe Tides you've heard me talk about
them before they are offering you $10
just for trying their free service at
debet eyes comm slash Pakman this is a
free app that will link your credit card
to your checking account and will
automatically withdraw from your
checking account however much you charge
to your credit card each day without
ever overdrafting at the end of the
month debe tais has effectively already
automatically paid your credit card bill
for you so you can earn miles credit
cards rewards points and build credit
without risking going into debt or
accruing interest or late fees it's
completely free and unlimited and debbye
ties will give you 10 bucks just for
trying it out but you'll also get access
to a one-month free trial of the debe
thaïs credit optimizer which helps your
credit score even more by keeping your
credit utilization low by paying off the
credit card every week I've talked about
this before on the show a lot and this
is a big deal because your credit
utilization accounts for roughly 30
percent of your credit score this is a
graph from creditkarma.com showing the
relationship between credit card
utilization and average credit score and
I have always
made it a habit to pay off my credit
card every single month keep my credit
utilization rate low and I have a pretty
good credit score I will admit that I'm
comfortable admitting that I'm fully
comfortable many of the people who use
the debe thaís credit optimizer have
been able to increase their credit score
by over fifty points but all of debet
eise's other services like the first one
I mentioned are totally free and always
will be you can get access to all of
this only by clicking the link
underneath this video